so today my job is to make all my
friends blow up that sounds weird but
it's not as weird as some of the things
that happen around here
[Music]
the challenge here is to make it crazy
gruesome without being like gory which
involves basically just changing the
color of the blood so the first step
involved in doing this stuff is to
actually erase the people and that
involves comping in the clean plate
which has no one in it when we explode
we're actually still there but we're
underneath like a blanket of
invisibility this is this is the very
beginning of a vfx shot and i have yet
to even begin working on this so
hopefully i can get this shot done in a
matter of hours definitely hopefully
before the end of the day
but i tracked in the clean place so now
it's a flawless cut so what that means
is now i can start adding in blood stuff
so here's the thing on the battlefield
rush series that sam nico directed sam
had to do some lessons
definitely could use a couple tweaks not
big but like well like what i mean
the video goes out in like a day well
i'm just saying there's a couple funky
things i'm glad it was sped up but like
there's just a couple beats that like
just i think we've used over which are
worth keeping for the sake okay comedy
here's the issue is that the trains are
rolling so you need to get in contact
with kevin who's currently readjusting
the music it's going up thursday yeah
it's basically needs to be done by
tomorrow
oh okay well
we should discuss it as a big group
what's going on sorry so i watched it
it's great it's funny the jokes aren't
hitting basically anymore it's kind of
joking whoa see that's like not as funny
anymore for some reason i'm just gonna
go into basically those three little
moments i'm just gonna look
i say today focus on finishing the
effects on your list if things are if
they progress on the timeline you
expected and you're not going to get to
the tweaks today don't get to the tweaks
today if you can find an hour you need
at the beginning or end of the day to do
the tweaks i think we'd be good
oh man is this the the bombshell thing
yeah dude so i guess first things first
this is a sponsored video and i'm really
excited about this one because it means
i get new clothes that's what it means
here's some talking points bombfell is
an online personal styling service it's
fully personalized that means you have
an actual stylist picking out the
clothes directly for you
and your stylist will email you their
selections at which point you'll have 48
hours to make a final review it's the
most simple straightforward service
around in fact you can even keep all the
stuff that you want and return the stuff
that you don't want for no extra charges
there's no hidden fees or oh god
yeah so they're super flexible super
chill you can push delay or even skip
any orders you want at any time you know
what i'm ready to open this are we done
with the talking points i want to open
this
oh my god i'm like trying to pull the
bag off and i can't because my thumb
went through the hole and was holding
the bag closed
all right hey check that out it's a
t-shirt man look at these pants are they
pants or shorts i literally went through
the process of like talking to the
stylist and all this and i don't even
remember what i got
yeah dude yeah his name was will cool
guy he stylized myself because i'm not
very good at stylizing myself
that's pretty cool you should do a spin
transition where you spin and then it
turns into clothes oh i wonder how many
spins i can do from jumping how many
spins can you do in the air
one
and a half and a half so sam nico
directed this series called rush that
was on go 90. sam had to do some last
minute visual effects and one of those
effects was this tank blowing up a dude
just like
he actually simulated cloth tearing of a
couple different squares and simulated
them being shredded apart and being
blown up and when you put in blood
elements on top of that it starts
looking like flesh i literally took the
exact same project file that sam
simulated this on and i threw it into
octane and i just literally just rotated
it three times so i have four different
angles but it's the same element just
render from different directions so they
appear like they're different here's the
original footage here's with the clean
plates and the people on top it looks
almost the same from there i can
actually activate it so that a mask
turns on and removes me from them so
that's like one by one we're gonna drop
out just like
so then i just i layered in that blood
element
it's tracked in with the footage there's
motion blur in it i shifted it to blue
so it goes down i even have some ambient
occlusion here's without ambient
occlusion here's width ambient occlusion
is literally just darkness calculated by
how close you are to another object so
the closer you are the darker you get
it's a form of shading it adds more
depth and like visual shape to a render
so then i even animated me turning into
blue squibs so it's like
and so here's the actual like effect
i finally know the direction to take
this effect shot i have five people to
blow up and i've blown up one and it
works i'm gonna continue that method
with the other four
okay this is the shirt you're a stylish
dude what do you think i think you look
good
not bad vomfeld not bad will they feel
great wow they're like these are like
the softest pants i've ever had that
aren't like sweatpants or fleece
something
okay i'm ready to party it seems to fit
just fine take advantage of our sweet
unique offer here by getting 25 off your
first order from bombfell.com forward
slash saminiko that's
b-o-m-b-f-e-l-l.com all you gotta do is
sign up make a profile approve your
order and then just wait for the clothes
to drop on your doorstep from the
mailman
lock your dogs up because he'll bite the
mail man and then you'll lose your dog
and be sad forever because you didn't
get bomb fell clothing why would your
dog fight your dad
oh sad
4 31 in 55 seconds six seconds what's up
i'm going through lifeline edits right
now i mean it's there's a kind of a
[ __ ] with the way this project
being edited right now because we're
editing pieces another one of our
producers editing pieces simultaneously
it's getting really confusing personally
have been pretty checked out with the
whole editing process like you know i
threw some notes in but the funny thing
is is that this producer his cuts are
actually way better like than the stuff
we're doing right now we are trying to
refine the edits to like match what we
intended to shoot and he is refining the
edits with the intention of telling
a better story so it's turning out
really well and you know he's trying to
make really good episodes and they're
currently really good episodes actually
like his like already look feel and look
like a legit episode and so it's going
great
what have you learned
communicate the plan before people start
working so i basically did that same
effect that i did to myself to everyone
else
[Music]
so yeah i didn't expect it to go this
direction of just like i'm going to make
them balloon people that pop i say that
now but then sam's going to come in and
be like actually uh no let's go get sam
i think i'm done with this vfx if you
want to take a look
all righty
here we go i had a bunch of like sparks
and a little like smoked poops better be
good
whoa
okay i mean it better be but yeah
honestly the smallest thing that would
really help is just like a little like
micro like flare out like for each one
just a little punch literally an optical
flare like literally just a tiny little
flare just to see that
for like the
so basically sam wanted a lens flare
because the laser bolt is like super
bright so if a lens actually saw that
yeah there'd be some flaring that's what
happens when you point the lens at like
bright things
yeah i'd write that out screw it do it
sweet all right here here you ready i'm
gonna put this come come closer
[Applause]
finally finished the effects finally
finally fortunately sam made his
additional edit tweaks this morning i'm
going to make the final export right
here right now fortunately everything
got done i don't know why it was such a
big deal
why this is the limited edition katakana
corridor hat roughly sounds out corridor
in katakana chorus there's no time for
this nico all you need to know is that
this sale to get this hat ends tomorrow
night friday the 26th end of day there's
not gonna be a sam nico video going up
to remind you nico there's no time for
any of this if you don't buy it now
you'll never be able to get it again
first take second try
but i'm changing the edit and
all right